பெரிய அளவில நடக்கும் கர்மங்கள், நடுவில நம்முடைய கண்காதுக்கு நாக்கமுக்கொழியா, எதை நம்ம தெரிய முடிவோம், உணர முடிவோம் அந்த மாதிரி கர்மங்கள்.
அது மாதிரி ஒரு மூனா பிரிக்கலாம். இதில் நம்முக்குள் நடக்கும் இந்த உடம்புக்குள் நடக்கும் வெளியில் மைக்ரோ வெளியில் நடக்கும் விஷயங்கள் எத்தனைமுக்கும் மில்லியன்ஸ் வெளியில் நடக்குமா இருக்கும்.
அதே போல மைக்ரோ வெளியிலும் ஒரு உணர்ஸ் முழுக்கு நம்முடைய பூமிக்கும் மேலியே நடக்கும் விஷயங்கள். இது நம்ம இப்படி ஒரு விவிஷன் செய்யலாம்.
அடுத்தது எந்தக் கர்மாவை நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் இருப்பதா என்று நினைக்கிறோம்.
நம்முடைய நடத்துரம், நம்முடைய முழுவாக நடக்கும் என்பது பொதுவாக மில்லியல் இருப்பது மட்டும்தான் நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் இருக்கும் கர்மா என்று நினைக்கிறோம்.
படிக்கிறோம், பேசுகிறோம், பார்க்கிறோம், எழுதுகிறோம், நடக்கிறோம், யாரையோ சந்தித்து நம்முக்குள்ள ஒரு வக்கில் தொழிலை, ஒரு மருத்துவர் தொழிலை, அதைத் தொழிலுக்காகப் பயன்படுகிறோம்.
சாப்பிடுகிறோம், நமக்கு இந்த மிடுல் லெவெல்ல இருக்கிற கர்மா மட்டும்தான் நாம் வந்து நடத்துறோம், அல்லது நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் இருக்கு, நீ போனேன், போய் திக்கிட் வாங்கினேன் அப்படியென்பது எல்லாம்.
சாப்பிடுகிறோம், நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் லெவெல் நடந்துகொண்டு இருக்கிறோம், சாப்பிடுகிறோம், நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் லெவெல் நடந்துகொண்டு இருக்கிறோம்,
நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் லெவெல் நடந்துகொண்டு இருக்கிறோம், சாப்பிடுகிறோம், நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் லெவெல் நடந்துகொண்டு இருக்கிறோம், சாப்பிடுகிறோம், நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் லெவெல் நடந்துகொண்டு இருக்கிறோம்,
நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் லெவெல் நடந்துகொண்டு இருக்கிறோம், சாப்பிடுகிறோம், நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் லெவெல் நடந்துகொண்டு இருக்கிறோம், சாப்பிடுகிறோம்
நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் லெவெல் நடந்துகொண்டு இருக்கிறோம், சாப்பிடுகிறோம், நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் லெவெல் நடந்துகொண்டு இருக்கிறோம், சாப்பிடுகிறோம், நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் லெவெல் நடந்துகொண்டு இருக்கிறோம், சாப்பிடுகிறோம்
நம்முடைய கண்டுரலில் லெவெல் நடந்துகொண்டு இருக்கிறோம், சாப்பிடுகிறோம்